نعم ميسون قبل ان اكون معكم على الهواء
مباشره التقيت باحد عمال الانقاذ احد
المتطوعين الذي ينتمي او هو عضو في هيئه
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد اخف منهم
معلومات كثيره وكانت مهمه حقيقه عن السير
عمليات الانقاذ في هذا
الموقع اولا طبعا اخبرني بانه صباح هذا
اليوم انفجر هذا اليوم تم اخراج شخص كان
على قيد الحياه من تحت الركام
عفوا
تم اخراجه فجر هذا اليوم مع الاسف لم
نتمكن او لم نكن موجودين هنا لنقل هذا
الخبر السار وتلك الصوره التي كانت هنا في
هذا الموقع
عفوا مره ثانيه فجر هذا اليوم اذا تم
اخراج شخص كان على قيد الحياه في هذا
الموقع اكد لي ايضا انهم
خليني اعطيك وقت زيدان اذا مش مرتاح ربما
من الغبار في تلك المنطقه اعطيك مشي الحال
اكيد
ان شاء الله
اخبرني ايضا انهم هناك يعني تفاؤل كبير
جدا جدا بوجود اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه تحت هذا المبنى حيث ان قبل قليل
اتى فريق متخصص معه كاميرات مراقبه حراريه
تم فحص الموقع هناك ثلاث نقاط في هذا
الموقع يقومون بالحفر في داخلها ويقومون
ايضا
بطبعا باشراف فريق متخصص ايضا فريق الذي
الفريق الكلاب المدربه الذي وصل الى هذا
الموقع وهو متواجد في هذا الموقع اكد لنا
المشرف على الكلاب المدربه ان الكلاب
المدربه كانت تعطي اشارات بوجود اشخاص ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه هذه يعني يعني هذا
هو احت لكن احتمال كبير بان يكونوا
مازالوا على قيد الحياه وما عزز هذه الفرص
هو نجاه شخص كما ذكرنا او انتشار شخص كان
بقي على قيد الحياه اليوم الرابع منذ حدوث
هذا الزلزال
مدى سهوله في ظل انه تركيا لديها الاليات
على الاقل وربما عدد كبير من العاملين مدى
سهوله الوصول الى هؤلاء
حقيقه ميسون رغم كل الامكانيات والاليات
الموجوده لكن الموضوع الوصول الى العالقين
تحت الانقاض وخصوصا اذا كان مثل هذا
البناء 14 طابقا يعني نحن يوم امس كان
العمل عند الطابق السابع وعندما ازالوا
بعض الركام قالوا ان هذا ركام هو من
الطابق السابع من خلال بعض المحتويات او
التي كانت بعض الاثاثات التي كانت مكسره
وتعرف عليها اصحاب بعض المنازل او الذين
كانوا موجودين هنا فتبين انها في الطابق
السابع يعني الموضوع ليس بهذه السهوله
خصوصا عندما يكون هناك شكوك ان هناك اشخاص
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه يتم العمل بهدوء
رغم كل هذه الاليات التي نشاهدها لكن في
نقاط معينه وهي النقاط الاساسيه التي يتم
الحفر همم عندها الحفر يكون باليات بسيطه
جدا منعا او خوفا من هبوط بعض الركام فوق
الاشخاص الذين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
نقطه اخرى اخبرني بها المتطوع ميسون ان
معظم الاشخاص سواء كانوا الجثث او الناجين
الذين استطاعوا انتشالهم من هذا المبنى
كانوا
في الدرج يعني اثناء نزولهم من السلالم
بعد وقوع الزلزال انهار البناء وتقريبا
معظم الجثث الذين كانوا التي اخرجوها او
حتى الناجين كانوا عالقين بين السلالم في
الطواب في طوابق هذا البناء عندما انهار
هذا البناء لحظه حدوث الزلزال طبعا مع
الاسف اخبرني انهم وجدوا بعض اجزاء متفرقه
لضحايا مثلا يد مقطوعه او قدم مقطوعه
جدا على الجميع